what ever happened to chucky  gee where the hell are you you're the  only one i can talk to about what really  happened  it's been a really tough year  are you  as happy as you made me  [Music]  who is this  and why the hell are you calling to make  sure you're home  this cross mr evans and mr wheeler  do you know why you're here i know your  history  it's just a dog  [Applause]  when do we get to start stabbing people  no matter what he's gonna come for us  again  i hate that doll  i need tiffany  to get what's coming to her  go in glinda come to mama  let go  dear sweet godmother hail mary jesus  this is for kyle  hi  i'm chucky  wanna pray  just looking at me is scary enough to  give you a heart attack  oh my god thank you  you